hey this is presh showwalker
the Putnam competition is an annual exam
for undergraduate students in the United
States and Canada you have three hours
to solve six problems and then you have
another three hours to solve another six
problems so you're taking six hours to
solve 12 questions
now each question is worth 10 points for
a maximum of 120 points
the median score is about one point even
though the students taking it are
exceptionally good at math
so this is a very difficult competition
this question comes from the 1980 Putnam
competition problem A3
evaluate the integral from 0 to pi over
2 of DX divided by one plus tangent x to
the power of root 2.
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
there's actually a remarkable trick to
solve this problem in seconds
it's known as the king's role or King's
property of definite integrals
the integral from A to B of f of x
divided by F of a plus B minus X Plus f
of x DX is equal to B minus a over two
so how does this help us solve this
question
so tangent of X is equal to sine of x
divided by cosine X so we can substitute
in this integral goes from 0 to pi over
2 of DX divided by one plus sine X
raised to the power of root 2 divided by
cosine X raised to the power of root 2.
we can multiply the numerator and
denominator by cosine X raised to the
power of root 2.
so this simplifies to the integral from
0 to pi over 2 of cosine X to the power
of root 2 DX divided by cosine X to the
power of root 2 plus sine X to the power
of root 2.
and now we have an integral in exactly
the form we want
let f of x be equal to cosine of x to
the power root 2.
then what is f of a plus B minus X
now A plus b is equal to zero plus pi
over two so that's equal to pi over 2.
so F of pi over 2 minus X is equal to
cosine of pi over 2 minus X we want the
entire thing raised to the power of root
2. the cosine of pi over 2 minus X is
exactly equal to sine of x so F of pi
over 2 minus X is equal to sine of x to
the power of root 2.
so we can exactly apply King's Rule and
this integral is equal to pi over 2
minus 0 divided by 2 which equals pi
over four and that's the answer
we can even generalize this one step
further there's nothing special about
the exponent of root 2. we can
substitute this for any real number K
and we're going to get exactly the same
result
the integral from 0 to pi over 2 of DX
divided by 1 plus tangent x to the power
of K is equal to pi over four
there's an interesting visualization
all of these graphs will have exactly
the same area
this is very interesting
so now to be rigorous I'm going to
present a proof of the formula
so let's say we have the integral from A
to B of f of x divided by F of a plus B
minus X Plus f of x DX
let this integral be equal to I we will
do a substitution that U is equal to a
plus B minus X then d u is equal to
negative DX
as we made a substitution we also want
to check the limits of integration
when X is equal to a u will be equal to
B and when X is equal to b u will be
equal to a
so we end up with the integral from B to
a of f of a plus B minus 2 divided by F
of U plus F of a plus B minus U negative
d u
now this integral is also equal to I
now we can flip the limits of
integration and cancel it out with this
negative d u
so we end up with the integral from A to
B and we have a d u
in this integral U is just a placeholder
variable so we can change all instances
of U with x
so now we have two different forms of
the same integral I
so we'll do a trick We'll add these two
integrals together
so when we do that one result will be 2i
the other result will be the integral
from A to B of f of x plus F of a plus B
minus X over f of x plus a plus B minus
X DX
now we can simplify this the numerator
and denominator are exactly equal to
each other so they will vanish to be
equal to one
so the integral of a to B of DX and that
will evaluate just to be B minus a
dividing both sides by 2 we get that I
is equal to B minus a over two and that
exactly proves the formula remember this
trick and you'll be able to solve many
integrals very quickly
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
thank you